[موسيقى]
طب ثم وطبت اوقاتكم ما نواصل هذه التغطيه
من العربيه للانتخابات النصفيه الامريكيه
اذا ايضا يواصل الامريكيون التصويت في
انتخابات التجديد النصفي للكونغرس وفتحت
مراكز الاقتراع في الساحل الشرقيه او
ابوابها منذ ساعات الصباح الباكر لكن متى
يمكننا معرفه اي حزم باتت بيده الاغلبيه
بعد تلاقي الناخبيننا لاصواتهم اليوم
مقادير يستغرق انتظار النتائج الليله
طويله وربما ايام قبل ان يتضح ما اذا كان
الجمهوريون او الديمقراطيون هم من فازوا
وسيطروا على الكونجرس يتوقع كثيرون موجه
ضخمه من الدعم للحزب الجمهوري وضغط كبير
من الرئيس السابق ترامب وهو ما يمكن ان
تؤدي الى او يؤدي الى اعلان الجمهوريين
النصر بعد ساعات من اغلاق صناديق الاقتراع
لكن عده ولايات رئيسيه مثل السلفانيا سبقت
هذا الامر بالاعلان عن ان اي فرز فرزه كل
البطاقات بطاقات الاقتراع قد يستغرق اياما
هناك مساله اخرى وهي التصويت عبر البريد
بعض الولايات تفرز الصناديقها مبكرا قبل
يوم الانتخابات ما قد يرجح كافه حزب على
حزب اخر وبعض ولايات اخرى لا تبدا العد
الا في نفس يوم الانتخابات لذا وتحديد
الاصوات بالبريد عمليه قد تستغرق اياما
وكيفك
معنى من اللذه فيجاس في نيفادا مراسله
العربيه للتسليمان وكذلك طلال الحاج من
نيويورك اهلا بكمام لابدا اولا ااا مع
ريتا وهناك ايضا الاوضاع المختلفه ريتا
يعني اليوم دعيني اعرف خبريه اولا كيف
التجري عمليات التصويت وما هو الجديد لديك
افتتحت مراكز الاقتراح هنا في نيفادا
وتحديدا في لاس فيغاس نحن الان ناقص امام
مركز للاقتران في لاسبيغاز همم
طابور كبير من الناخبين المسترجلين
للادلاء باصواتهم قبل افتتاح مركز همم
تحدثنا مع بعضهم وقالوا لنا انهم متحمسين
تلاقي باصواتهم مع همم بدايه فتح المراكز
السابعه همم صباحا تماما بتوقيت
الغربي للولايات المتحده همم طبعا صوتهم
قبل الذهاب الى اعمالهم كما اخبرني همم
متحمسين للادلاء باصواتهم لانه السباق همم
بمشاهداداتك
نسبه الاطباء الكونتها الساعه 7:00 صباحا
انها جيده جدا وكان الناس كانوا منتظرين
في سياراتهم قبل ساعه او ساعه ونصف من
افتتاح هذا المركز تحديدا ما يعني انه
متحمسون متحمسون نوعا مال تلاقي باصواتهم
كون السباق الابرز في هذه الولايه بين هو
على مجلس الشيوخ تحديدا وبين السنه
الديمقراطيه همم كاسرين كورتاج ماستو
والمرشح الجمهوري ادم لاكسالد
اذا اذهب الى نيويورك وهناك اسال طلال
ماذا عن
نسبه الاقبال همم هي ايضا قد تشكل فارغا
اساسيا اليوم في عمليه الاقتراع
نعم الاقبال شديد وخاصه في التصويت المبكر
25 في المئه من الامريكيين هنا في ولايه
نيويورك يصوطون بريديه وايضا نسبه كبيره
منهم مليون ونصف تقريبا صوتوا مبكرا في
الفتره ما بين 27 اكتوبر وحتى السادس منه
نوفمبر وترى نحن هنا امام مؤسسه فورد
الخيريه وترى الناس
الزجاجي وترى الناس ورائي
هذا الموضوع منذ صباح يعني اقبال جيد حتى
الان وفق ما ترى من حيث انت من الساعد من
الساعه السادسه صباحا من الساعه السادسه
صباحا عادل همم
يفيدون الى هذا المكان ومراكز اقتراع اخرى
في منهات في ولايه في مدينه نيويورك وفي
ولايه نيويورك الاجلاء بالاصوات يدركونا
اهميه هذه الانتخابات النصفيه
عليها
كثير من الاشياء ستبنى مستقبلا وخاصه
التحكم في هذه الولايات ان الحاكم او
الحاكمه هنا كاترين هوجن تواجه همم
صراحه المنافسه كبيره ولاول مره منذ 20
سنه لم يحكم هذه الولايه حاكم الجمهوريه
اخر شخص هو جورج بيتاكي واذكره جيدا لانني
قابلته عام 98 في مؤتمر الحزبيه
للجمهوريين في كاليفورنيا وكان حاكم اللي
يوكل لمده 12 سنه وكان شخصا دا مثل الخلق
ولكن من ذلك الحكي منه 2002 الى هذه
اللحظه لم يوجد
يوم الجمهوري لهذه الولايات وتعرف عن
السنه ثور جاء همم
لربما انت لست في اول انتخابات وبالتالي
لك ايضا رؤيتك على الارض وقراءهتك الصحفي
بالتاكيد سنعود للحديث عن نيويورك وكل
التفاصيل الدقيقه بعد قليل في سياقي هذه
التغطيه بالتاكيد شكرا
لطلال الحاج حتى الان وكذلك رتبوا معنا
سنعود اليكم للحديث حول همم هذه
الانتخابات
طيب ايضا النتائج الدورات الانتخابيه
الاخيره حددت ولايه نيفادا كاحدى اهم
الولايات المتارجحه حاليا يسيطر
الديمقراطيون على نيفادا مع هيمنه على
تمثيلها في مجلس الشيوخ بعضويتين في مجلس
النواب ثلاثه ديمقراطيين من نواب الولايه
الاربعه كما يحكم الولايه حاكم ديموقراطي
كذلك وزير خارجيه الولايه اي الشخص
المسؤول عن تنظيم واداره وتوفيق
الانتخابات الرئاسيه لكن الجمهوريين هذا
العام يهددون الهيمنه الديمقراطيه السباق
متقارب بين مرشحي الحزبين على كل المناصب
بصوره غير مسبوقه هناك حيث يتخلف حاكم
ولايه نيفادا الديمقراطيستيف سيسولاك عن
منافسه الجمهوريه
المتمتع بدعم من قوي
امم
باربع نقاط مئويه طبعا هو متفوق وفقا
استطلاع اميرسون كوليج ذهب ويقلل من نقاط
المرشح الديمقراطي كذلك غضب سكان نيفادا
ومعاناتهم من معدلات التضخم الاعلى نسبيا
في البلاد تبيعاتها من ارتفاع لاسعار
الوقود وكذلك المواد الغذائيه بالاضافه
الى اثار الاغلاق خلال جائحه كره
البيانو
[موسيقى]
اما مقعد ولايه نيفادا في مجلس الشيوخ
فيعد افضل فرص الجمهوريين لحصد مقعد اضافي
وامال لهم الاغلبيه هنا المواجهه تشمل
السيناتورا ديمقراطيه كاثرين كورتيز ماستو
واسيناتور الجمهوري ادم
تشير معظم استطلاعات الراي الى نسب تاييد
متعادله تقريبا بين المرشحين رغم ان ماستو
اول سيده لاتينيه تشغل مقعدا في مجلس
الشيوخ الا ان كتله الناخبين اللاتينيين
الذين تبلغ نسبتهم نحو 30% من سكان
الولايه يميلون
للمرشحه او المرشح للجمهوريه وفقا
استطلاعات الراي في وقت همم تذهب اغلبيه
اصوات الناخبين التي لهنا تقليديه الى
الديمقراطيين فان ديمقراطيه نيفادا
قلقون لاسيما ان نسبه المصوتين اللاتينين
لصالح ترامب زادت منذ انتخابات 2016 الى
انتخابات 2020 بمقدار ثماني نقاط هنا هذا
هنا هذا هو الاختبار يتمثل بقدره
الديمقراطيين على تفعيل ال الدفع الناخبين
للتصويت لمواجهه الزخم الكبير الذي يمسكه
الجمهوريون
تلمسنا الطريق في نيفادا وبعد الولايات
لكن ماذا عن الاقتراع دعونا نرى هذه
المراكز مراكز الاقتراع في لوس انجلوس
وكذلك في نيويورك اما بعض
المؤشرات تشير الى اقبال جيد نسبيا في
فترات الصباح كما اشار اا المراسلون الى
ان نسبه اقبال جيده وكذلك حتى نسبه
المصوتين قبيله هذه الانتخابات كانت نسبه
لا باس بها كما اشار مراسل العربيه طلال
الحاج من نيويورك الى ان نسبه 25% كانت
نسبه المصوتين اللي همم او المخترعين
قبيله هذه الانتخابات اذا سنعود الى شبكه
المراسلين وتحديدا مني بعد مراسله العربيه
لتسليمان وكذلك من نيويورك طلال الحاج
الى همم طلال الان
نعم طلال كنا نتحدث بان هذه المره
الديمقراطيون يخشون من ان تكون نيويورك
جمهوريه هل هذا واقعا ام مفاجاه قد تحدث
بين قوسين يمكن استشرافها حتى قبل عمليه
الفرز
ام من الصعوبه
بناء على خبر
بنسبه 30 الى 20% همم
متفوقه على على
منافسها الجمهوري همم
زلزل
والان هو متفوق عليها بنسبه فاصل صفر سته
في العاشر يعني اقل من واحد في سته في 10%
همم لذلك هناك زخم كبير من التاييد لهذا
المرشح الجمهوري والسبب هو في واقع الامر
انخفاض شعبيه الرئيس التي ترجع صعودا
وهبوطا في الاربعينيات في المياه 40%
تحتاج الى 50 او 51% على الاقل لانه نصف
الشعب يحبك ويؤيدك ولكن عندما تصبح في
الاربعينات في المئه همم هذا يدل على
شعبيه هذا الرئيس ارتفاع نسبه الفوائد
ارتفاع اسعار الاغذيه بالاضافه الى الوقود
الطاقه كل هذه العوامل همم
تجعل من هذه الاداره اداره غير ذات شعبيه
حتى في ولايه همم
ديمقراطيه بامتياز همم لان هذه اساسيات
الحياه لا يهمه المواطن الامريكي اذا كان
هناك حرف في اوكرانيا او كان هناك كوفد
وجائحه همم تعامل العالم كله ما يريده فهو
مدلل الى حد كبير وكل ما يريده هو طعامه
وسياراته وقوده الطاقه باسعار همم رخيصه
تعود عليها وليد هذا الارتفاع في الواقع
في الاسعار وفي الفوائد وفي همم الوقود
والطاقه الكهربائيه كله ذلك يؤثر على
الناقد الامريكي الذي لا يعيره هما
للاسباب او
حقيقه الواقعه في كل انحاء العالم لذلك
نتوقع في واقع الان تكون هذه
الانتخابات صعبه جدا
الديمقراطيين وارجو ارجو ان يفوز
[موسيقى]
بمنصب حاكم الولايه او رئيس رئيس
الديمقراطين
النتائج طلال صحيح اسمح لي ان اذهب الى
ريتا اذا تكرمت ريت سليمان هل هذه المشاكل
التي تحدث في نيويورك همم يبدون فصل طيب
سنعود الى هذه بعد قليل
اريتما- نعاود الاتصال طيب
يبدو انه راح نعطيكم مجالك اكثر همم حتى
نستفيد من ايضا قراءتك في نيويورك اليوم
هذه المشاكل هي ليست المره الاولى التي
تمر على الولايات المتحده ازمات اقتصاديه
ولكن لماذا
هذه هذه المره
الديمقراطيون وضعهم لا اريد ان اقول هشا
ولكنه ليس مريحا
الوضع صعب جدا لملاحظه في هذه الولايه ولا
في الولايات المتحده ان يرتفع سعر همم
قالوا له الوقود الى السته الدولارات او
سبعه دولارات بعد ان كانت جولارين
الاسعار تضاعفت الى ثلاثه اضعاف كل ذلك
همم يعني همم امتحن الصبر همم الناخب
الامريكي كما قلت هذه 70% من المواطنين
هنا ومسجلين همم في الحزب الديمقراطي
رسميا هذه الولايه من الاخر من اكبر
معاقين الديمقراطيين في الولايات المتحده
همم بالاضافه الى كاليفورنيا ولكن هم الان
يعتمدون في هذه الولايه على تاييد النساء
خاصه في قضيه حق الاجهاض في ولايه
الابراليه مثل نيويورك يعتمدون على تاييد
همم الجاليه السوداء الذين يحدرون من جذور
او اصول همم افريقيا حتى يفوزوا ان لم
يحصلوا على سيدنا النساء بالقدر الكافي او
السود هنا في هذه الولايه
فعلت ديموقراطيين السلام في هذه الولايه
الديمقراطيه المعقل الديمقراطي الاول ربما
بعد كاليفورنيا اا بالنسبه للجمهوريين
يعتمدون على مساله ضبط الامن ارتفعت
الجرائم حتى في القطارات نيويورك اصبحت
اصبح عدد القتلى بارقام قياسيه لم تراها
نيوك منذ عشرات السنين هذه نقطه ضعف كبير
طبعا باضافه الى غلاء اسعار الغذاء
والوقود
في اخر الامر وول ستريت قبل قليل اعلن
ارتفاع السوق البورصه الدوليه كل ذلك سرق
البورصه الدوليه هنا في نيوكا الذي هو نبض
للباصات العالميه لا يرتفع الا اذا كان
الجمهوريون قادمون ولذلك هم يستبشرون خيرا
بهذه الانتخابات واعتقدون ان الجمهوريين
سيفوزون
نعم
نحاول ان نسالها هل هذه المشاكل التي تحدث
عنها طلال في نيويورك هي ذات المشاكل التي
تتدفع الناخب في نيفادا الى الاتجاه الى
الخيار الاخر الجمهوري همم
يبتعد عن الديمقراطيين هل وضعهم ايضا غير
مريح في هذه الولايه
صحيح ربما وضع السنتر كاسر يعني كورتاج
ماسو هو الاكثر هشاشه والاكثر مخاطره بين
الديمقراطيين المرشحين في كل الولايات في
هذه الانتخابات النصفيه
الابرز بالنسبه لكثرين هو الاقتصاد خاصه
كانت الولايه الاكثر تاثرا بالاخلاق جراء
كورونا همم خاصه انه اقتصادها يعتمد على
السياحه وهمم على استقبال همم المواطنين
والسواح همم صله العام وهذا اثر على
اقتصادها كثيرا في سنوات الاخلاق واتى من
بعدها التضخم ليقضي على اي امل بالتعافي
همم اقتصاديا في نافاده كما امم يمكن ان
نضيف عامل مهم ربما لا وجود له بمناطق
اخرى في الولايات المتح تردد الديمقراطيه
يتمثل بانه رسائل التي يحاول الديمقراطيون
اعطائها للناخب في نيفادا ليست جذابه له
خاصه فيما يتعلق بالاجهاض مثلا فالاجهاض
هو همم عامل وقانون محمي في همم
بقوانينفاده همم حتى الان وبالتالي ليس
مهتما المواطن في نيفادا من همم مخاطر
خساره حق الاشهاد تحديدا
لماذا يتقدم بارد ايضا في هذا ما الذي
يعطيه الدفع للتقدم
هناك ايضا هذا الدعم الكبير من قبل الرئيس
ترامب وايضا هذا الحديث
عن
همم التزوير بالانتخابات السابقه بحسب ما
يتابع
ويتتابع دائما ترامب ويقول بهذه
الانتخابات وايضا العامل الاهم اعود واكرر
هو الابتسايد ثم الابتسايد ثم الاقتصاد
باي معنى بانه العامل البسيط الذين راح
على محطه الوقود ربما اا
بالامس التقيت بعامل لاتيني اييه قال لي
انا لست مهتما بمشروع الهجره انا مع
الهجره النظاميه ولكن ما يهمني هو ان اؤمن
لعائلتي همم الطعام مساء على طاوله العشاء
وليس ولا يهمني ابدا وضع المهاجرين تحديدا
سليمان وكذلك بالنيفادا وكذلك الشكر موصول
لزميل طلال الحاج من نيويورك سنكون
بالتاكيد مع كوما في سياق هذه التقطيع طيب
حول اخر المستجدات في الولايات المتحده
افتتحت المؤشرات الامريكيه على ارتفاع
اليوم الثلاثاء مع بدا التصويت في
انتخابات التجديد النصفي للكونغرس
وسجلت المؤشرات ارتفاعا بنحو فاصله اربعه
بالمئه مع ترقب المستثمرين للنتائج
الفصليه لبعض الشركات الامريكيه
الكبرى
[موسيقى]
اذن
ونعود لاستكمال هذه التغطيه
ونتلمس ايضا هل صراع بين الجمهوريين
والديمقراطيين للحصول على الغالبيه
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله يدخلوا عدد كبير من الجمهوريين
الى الانتخابات التشديد النصفيه في
الولايات المتحده وهم يؤكدونا على تصديقهم
لتزوير الانتخابات الرئاسيه لعام 2020
لصالح بيض على حساب ترامب بعض هؤلاء
الجمهوريين اذا نجحوا في الانتخابات
سيقولون قادرين على الاشرار على
الانتخابات عام 2014
انتخابات التجديد المصري مواجهه مصغره
لاخرى محتمله عام 2024 بين جوبيد ودنهال
في سباق السيطره على الكونجز والولايات
يدخل 249 مرشحا جمهوريا لانتخابات بدعمه
ترامب كلهم يرددون نظريته الشهير انتخابات
عام 2020 سرقه
[تصفيق]
جعل ترامب الاقتناع بانه كان فائزا في
انتخابات 2020 شرطا اساسيا في اي مرشح
يريد الحصول على دعمه وبالفعل ردد كثير من
كلامه
[تصفيق]
اتهامات التزوير لم تثبت مطلقا لكنها تظل
روايه صلبه ولها مستمعوها في قاعده الحزب
الجمهوري المواليه لترامب حسب معهد البحوث
فاكثر من مئه مرشح للمؤيد نظريه ترامب
لديهم فرصه جيده للغايه في الفوز
بالانتخابات
وهي مناصب تنفيذيه مهمه تسمح لمن فيها
بتنظيم الانتخابات والاشراف على الفرز
والمصادقه على النتائج وسيشرف هؤلاء بكل
تاكيد على انتخابات عام 2014
الاستعادتها اذا ما حسم قراره بالسعي نحو
المكتب البيضاوي مجددا
[موسيقى]
هو كمان كمبيوتر
اماني
نذهب او الان نذهب للكريست وهو المرشح
لمصب حكم ولايه فلوريدا
تستحقون حاكما يحارب من اجلكم في كل يوم
ولهذا
انتم تستحقون الخيار
[تصفيق]
حصلت على التعليم لاطفال
معلمين ايضا بالشكل الصحيح وان يحصل على
مرتبات مناسبه لهم ان يكون النظام
التعليميه رائع لانه مستقبل فلوريداك ويجب
ان نحمي بيئتنا البيئه ضروري جدا
لاقتصاديا كلنا نعرف ذلك السياحه كبيرا
فماذا يفعله دي سانتوس هو يهاجمه اكبر
اسباب السياحه لانهم يمارسون حق الخطاب
كفانا ذلك
نائمه وقافيه لفتره ولكنها ستستيقظ الليله
انتخابات تكون عظيمه وتطلع نتائجها واتمنى
ان تحضر جميعا هذا المساء اشكركم على
حضوركم وبارك الله في ولايه كورد الجميله
شكرا
[موسيقى]
نعود لمعرفه الواقع الامريكيه في هذه
الانتخابات وقراءه استشرافيه لها من
واشنطن معنا الباحث في الشان الامريكي
السيد احمد الحنطي وكذلك ايضا من واشنطن
الباحث في مؤسسه الدفاع عن الديمقراطيات
حسين عبد الحسين اهلا بكم
لابدا همم اولا مع السيد احمد اليوم هل
بالفعل الديمقراطيين ورسائل هم اللي همم
امريكي لم تعد جذابه لكي تدفعهم الى
المضيء الى الصناديق الاقتراع والتصويت
لصالح الديمقراطيين هل هذا
هذا صحيح ولكنه ليس جديدا يعني
الديمقراطيين طول عمرهم ضعيفين في
المساجين في صياغه الرسائل للناخبين وهذه
الدوره يعني شهدت تفاقم لهذا الامر لانهم
في تركيزهم على موضوع الديمقراطيه يعني
انه اذا كسب الجمهوريين هذه الانتخابات
فربما لا تحدث انتخابات الاخرى في امريكا
وتركيزهم على موضوع الاجهاض يعني همم
كذا الامرين فيهما مشاكل الامر الاول هو
امر نظري يعني لا يجتذب الكثير من
الناخبين يعني غالبيه الناخبين يرون لا
يستوعبون هذا الامر على انه خطر فعلي على
حياتهم او شيء مؤثر فيهم بشكل رئيسي يعني
فلا يهتمون به كثيره موضوع عن الاجهاض
يعني قد يكون قد تكون الرساله جيده في ال-
في الولايات المتارجحه وربما حتى في
الولايات الحمراء ولكنه في الولايات
الزرقاء او التي تميل للزرقاء تاثيرها
ضعيف لانه الناخب يرى انه القوانين
المحليه تحمل الاجهاض تحمي حق الاجهاض
فبالتالي لا يهمني هذا الامر كثيرا لن
اخرج للتصويت للمرشح بسبب هذا الامر اريد
امر يعني اريد ان مرشح يتحدث لي عن امور
اخرى عن الاقتصاد عن التضخم عن الوظائف عن
هذه الامور اضافه الى انه مواجهه مشكله مع
يعني مع الحرب الثقافيه همم الجمهوريين
استطاعوا الانتصار في هذه الحرب عن طريق
التركيز على عمليه الوقف كثيرا يعني
ممكن لا يمثل نسبه كبيره من الديمقراطيين
ولكنه اذا نظرت لما يعني يدور في الاعلام
ست تحس ان هذا هو الشيء الوحيد وهذا الامر
مؤثر مؤثر مع المحافظين مؤثر مع المعتدلين
ومؤثر حتى مع المهاجرين المهاجرين يمنون
دائما المحافظه الاجتماعيه فلذلك مثل هذه
الرسائل يعني تنفرهم اكثر كل هذه الامور
اجتمعت لتضعف رساله الديمقراطيين في هذه
الدوره
التكرارا كما يحتاج باستمرار مع
الديمقراطيين اذهب الى سيد حسين عبد
الحسين الباحث في مؤسسه الدفاع عن
الديمقراطيه سيد حسين ما الذي يجعل خطاء
الخطاب الجمهوري الخطاب جاذبا هذه المره
او جذابا وبالتالي هل همم اليوم اتجاههم
الى
ربما ما يمس حياه الامريكي اقتصاديه همم
افضل من اتجاه الديمقراطيين
طبعا في اول مطاف حول الديمقراطيون ان
يجعله هذا السباق سباقا حول شخص الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب
ولم ينجح في ذلك لانه اعتقد انه رئيس
ترامب نجح في يعني الصمت والالتزام
بالرساله الاكبر التي قدمها الحزب
الجمهوري وهي التي تتمحور حول الاقتصاد
والاقتصاد طبعا هناك مشاكل تضخم وهذه
المشكله الاساسيه لانه الاقتصاد بشكل عام
اصلا هو ينمو معادلات البطاله منخفضه ولكن
التضخم يطال كل الفئات الاجتماعيه وهو اا
خطاب جامع يمر عبر كل الولايات لانه لو
تحدثنا مثلا عن مشاكل ارتفاع جريمه ارتفاع
جريمه هي في المدن الكبرى وضواحيها ولا
تطال المناطق او الولايات الريفيه يعني
التقييد للجمهوريه تاييد الاكبر
الجمهوريين ولو اخذنا يعني افكار اخرى
ايضا راينا الانتخابات عادت غالبا ما تكون
ترتبط بكل هي او بكل اقليم داخل الولايات
المتحده ولكن التضخم يشمل كل الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه الخمسين وهو مركز عليه
جمهوريون وهو ما لم ينجح الديمقراطيون في
التصدي له وحاوله نقل هذه الرساله الى
معركه حول شخص ترامب يبدو انهم لم ينجحوا
في ذلك ولكن طبعا نحن لا نعرف على الرغم
من الحديث عن موجه حمراء ولكن قد تكون
الفرص متكافئه حتى هل سينجح الديمقراطيون
ايضا بعدم تحويل هذه همم المعركه
الانتخابيه الى تقييم لشخصيات الرئيس او
حتى الحكم على سنتين من فتره حكمه سيد
حسين
يعني عاده في معظم الانتخابات الامريكيه
في التاريخ الحديث مع بعض الاستثناءات مثل
في ولايه جورج بوش الاولى عاده ما يخسر
الرئيس المنتخب في ولايته الاولى يخسر
الانتخابات المصريه وان لم يخسر بيدن هذا
يشيل انه هناك ضعف جمهوري اكثر من المتصور
ولذلك يعني التوقعات بالموجه الحمراء هي
يعني جزء منها يعني حول استطلاعات الراي
ولكن الجزء الاكبر هو حول المسار التاريخي
للامور للامور الانتخابيه في معظم
الولايات المتحده في هذا الموضوع طيب
السيد احمد الحنطي الباحث في شان الامريكي
اليوم الولايات المتحده همم ربما الملفات
التي طرحت نفسها اوكرانيا الملفات
الخارجيه العلاقات الدوليه بينها وبين
الصين وبين روسيا وحتى هنا في المنطقه هل
تمس همم ناخذ الامريكي ام انها ربما لا
تؤثر في ميزان همم
ساعه الناخب الامريكي من انه يذهب ليعطي
الديمقراطيين هناك امور اهم بالنسبه اليه
رفاهيه
[موسيقى]
تاريخيا العلاقات الخارجيه والسياسه
الدوليه لا تؤثر كثيرا على الناقب
الامريكي يعني هناك نسبه من الناخبين
يهتمون بهذا الامر ولكنهم اقليه ربما يكون
يعني هذه الدوره لانه فيها حرب يعني في
اوكرانيا قد يكون مؤثرا ولكن اللافته
الانتباه ان اداره بايدا يعني حاولت ان
تلقي بالذنب التضخم على هذه الحرب وفشلت
في ذلك لان الناس لم تقترب بهذه الرساله
طيب اليوم حتى هذه يعني قبل همم السويعات
كان جوبا ايضا يقول من ان في حال فوز
الجمهوريين ستكون واشنطن اول الحياه في
واشنطن ستكون صعبه عليه كيف يمكن
الجمهوريين ان ااه يصعب من مهمه بيضا خلال
السنتين القادمه حتى موعد الانتخابات
يعني هذا الامر يرتبط مجلس الشيوخ اكثر من
مجلس النواب لانه مجلس الشيوخ يجب ان
يعتمد التعيينات سواء كانت تعيينات يعني
تعيينات سياسيه بتعينات الحكوميه العليا
او كانت تعيينات قضائيه قد الجهاز
الحكوميه لن تكون كثيره لكن المشكله في
التعيينات القضائيه غالبا الجمهوريين
سيقفونها تماما كما فعلوا في اخر سنتين من
حكم اوباما هذه المشكله الكبرى التي تواجه
بايدا من ناحيه الكونجرس بالنسبه لمجلس
النواب ما لم تكن اغلبيه الجمهوريين كبيره
فلم تكون هناك مشكله كبيره لانه التع كان
متوقع من البدايه الديمقراطيين مرروا
تقريبا جميع جندتهم التشريعيه خلال اول
سنتين لم يكتفوا بمشروع واحد كبير مرروا
كل المشاريعه الكبرى وانتهى يعني لا
يضيرهم كثيرا ان يتعطل التشريع خلال سنتين
القادمه ولكن لو كانت الاغلبيه الجمهوريه
الكبيره فقط تبدا عمليات عزل محاولات عزل
بايدن وهذا سيشغل الاداره كثيرا في عمليات
عرائض ودفاع ومحاكمات الى اخ الى اخوه هذا
يعني سيسبب ازعاجا كبيرا يشغل الاداره عن
ادامها ليوميه الدعم همم الدعم من ترامب
لعدد من المرشحين سيد حسين هل يجعله كما
يقول عاد لينتقم وبالفعل كما قال السيد
احمد الحنطي منهم قد يذهبون لعزل
وهذا سيناريو على الاقل بعيد
بخصوص الدعم ترامب للمرشحين طبعا يعني لا
يوجد بيان خط بيان واضح هناك بعض المرشحين
من مندعهم فازوا وهناك جزء من من دعاهم
خسروا ولم يعترفوا حتى بالخساره يعني على
رغم انه انتخابات داخل حزبهم نفسه
همم اختار في اوقات اختار اصلا المرشح
الذي كان متقدما وفي احيان اخرى يعني لا
توجد بياء لا يوجد خط بيان واضح ويؤكد ان
كان هؤلاء المرشحون يفوزون لانه ترامب
زكاهم او لانهم مرشحون اقوياء من ناحيه
عزل الرئيس بيادر يعني هي شبه محسومه
والعزل هذا غالبا لا يكون لهدف العزل نفسه
يعني ارجع انه لا يتوقع الجمهوريون ان
ينجحوا في العزل ولكنه يتحول الى مسرح
سياسي كبير يعني كما فعلت الديمقراطيون
عندما همم
اتحاد الكونجرس من الجمهوريين فعلوا نفس
الشيء مع ترامب حاولوا كل الانتباه شتت
وكل الانتباه والانظار نحو ترامب همم
وبذلك عطلوا جزء كبير من عمل ترامب ومن
الاجنده التي كان ينوي ترامب تنفيذه في
هذه الحاله ان جاء الجمهوريون بموجه حمراء
حسب حسب ما يتوقع البعض ان كانت موجه
حمراء سيحصلون على غالبيه في مجلس النواب
كافيه همم لدرجه انهم سيتواجهون او
سيباشرون باجراءات العزل حتى لم تتواصل
الى شيء ولكن هذه الاجراء سيكون فيها
جلسات استماع تحقيق طلب تحقيق طلب الى
مسؤولين في همم اداره المثول امامهم
واستنطاقه هؤلاء وهذا طبعا كلها سيشكل
كابوس بالنسبه
ياخذ الجمهوريه خاصه انه يعني حديث عن
الانقسام حتى بين
الحزب الجمهوري سيد حسين يعني ما بين
ادعاء همم بانه سرقت ابات منها سابقا
مظلومومته في هذه الانتخابات وما حدث له
جراء الملفات السريه اذ هل من الممكن ان
يذهب بالحزب الجمهوري الى ابعد من ذلك في
الخامس عشر من هذا الشهر حاله اعلانه
الترشح لخوض الانتخابات
لا اظن انه هناك ابعد مما يعني
المشكله ههه طبعا ولكن المشكله الرئيسيه
هنا انه
ترامب يندفع الى اماكن هي ابعد يعني هي ضد
الديمقراطيه او يعني ما نسميها هنا انت
معادلات المؤسسه الحاكمه والحزب الجمهوري
اصلا تقليديا هو حزب المؤسسه الحاكمه يعني
هو حزب همم دعم الجيش وحسب دعم الشرطه هو
حزب دعم القوانين هو حزب الاصرار على انه
تكون الامور من داخل المؤسسات ومن داخل
المحاكم اسلوب ترامب هو انه هو من خارج
المؤسسه الحاكمه طبعا لان هو اصلا لما
يتدرج في يعني اي مناصب حكوميه قبل وصوله
الى الرئاسه هو ياتي من خارج المؤسسه
الحاكمه وهذا الاعداء للمؤسسه الحاكمه ادى
الانقسام داخل الحزب الجمهوري وراينا
اعداد كبيره همم ووجوه بارزه من امثال
وغيرهم رايناهم ينتفضون ضد هذه القياده
لترامب ويقولون نحن جمهوريون ونعارض
الاجنده الديمقراطيه ولكن في نفس الوقت
نحن لسنا مستعدين ان ننسف الجمهوريه ان
نقود اسس الديمقراطيه والانتخابات ولا
نعترف بالانتخابات او بالعمل الديمقراطي
بشكل عام طيب كباشرنا السيد احمد همم
الحنطي يعني فشل الديمقراطيين من توجيه
سهامهم على ترامب وتحويل هذه المعركه الى
شخص ترامب هل من الممكن اليوم همم ان
يعالج قضيه سوء اداره
تجاه القضايا الاقتصاديه وبالتالي يمكن ان
يحضون بفرصه ثانيه ان ذلك مستعد وفقا كل
هذه المؤشرات على الاقل حتى اسواق المال
الامريكيه
جمهوريين قادمون خلاص انتخابات اليوم
اليوم اكيد اليوم احنا اولاد اليوم
ولكن طلعت
الريفه منها الاخطاء اللي تكررت
نفس الاتجاه في ثلاث دورات متتاليه تبدا
تشك في انهم لم يستطيع اكتشاف الخلل
والبحمل على اصلاح هذا واحد معظم شركات
الاستطلاع الكبرى اللي يعني تخرج
استطلاعات موثوقه وتنشر كل التفاصيل بحيث
انه الجميع يعرف كيف اجرى هذا الاستطلاع
كيف اجره حساباتهم يعني كل دقيقه كبيره
بجوده هذا الاستطلاع اغلبهم لم يصدروا
استطلاعات كثيره هذه السنه او حتى لم
يشتروا استطلاعات ابدا بالتالي ان الارقام
التي لدينا ليست ارقام موثوقه لنستطيع ان
نتاكد منها ماذا سيحدث قد تحدث مفاجاه
الجميع هذه الليله ولكننا يعني افضل مؤشر
لدينا هو الاستطلاعات حتى لو كانت ضعيفه
فنحنا مع هذا المؤشر الى ان يظهر ما يعرف
فاذا ما اتمنى من الخلل سيد حسين بهذا
الاستطلاعات يعني اذا كان الشارع الامريكي
قدينيا ينتظر النقاط بين المرشحين همم
اللي معرفه الفارق وربما يؤثر ذلك حتى في
قراره للانتخابي اذا لم يكن هناك مؤسسه من
الممكن ان تطرح هكذا همم استطلاع كما يشير
السيد احمد ما الخلل وين
الخلل انه الاستطلاعات اصلا بطبيعتها هي
موضوع تقريبي لانه الاستطلاع راي غالبا
يشمل 1000 او 2000 مستطلع ولكن يعني
الولايات المتحده بلد فيها 350 مليون
فيتعذر الحكم يعني بعينات صغيره من هذا
النوع ولكن يعني كنا نقول انه تاريخيا
الحزب المعارض يفوز في الانتخابات النصفيه
في الدوره الاولى للرئيس الحاكم ولكن لو
نظرنا الى الانتخابات المبكره التي قام
بها الامريكيون اليوم طلعت يعني الارقام
صباحا همم يعني لو طلعنا هذه الارقام تبدو
انه الموجه هي زرقاء لانه الديمقراطيه
نتقدمون على جمهوريين باربعه مليون و700
الف صوت بس هذه هذه حتى في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه كان الديمقراطيون اكثر تصويطا
تصويت المبكر ولا لا
صحيح صحيح وفازه في نهايه المطاف فل
الموضوع انه لا يعني هذه الارقام لا يجب
ان تكون بهذا الشكل المشكله الثانيه طبعا
اعتقد انه ما يقلق الديمقراطيين وعدد كبير
من الجمهوريين هو قضيه عدم الاعتراف وهذه
القضيه اصلا ستتكرر في بنسلفانيا وقام
اليوم قامت الحملات الديمقراطيه يعني
التواصل مع وسائل الاعلام لانذارهم انه
مشكله بنسلفانيا انه كل التصويت المبكر
والذي ياتي عبر البريد
يحضر القانون لا يحرض يحضر فرزه قبل
السابعه صباحا من اليوم الذي يلي يوم
الانتخابات يعني تم الفرز همم حتى منتصف
الليل ولكن صباحا تاتي صناديق جديده ما
يحصل عاده انه يتقدم الجمهوريون مساءا ثم
تاتي صناديق الاصوات المبكره ويتقدم عندي
دقيقه لك استاذ احمد الديمقراطيه هل
يختطفوها ترامب
يمكن ان يشكل ترامب عداء كما يقول
الديمقراطيون همم وتهديدا للمؤسسات
المؤسسات الدوله بدقيقه واحده اذا تكرم هل
هذا الخطاب جاذب اذا ما فازت اذا ما فازت
رام في انتخابات 24 اذا ما ترشح اولا ثم
فاز فقد يحدث هذا نحن راينا محاوله جاده
منه يعني ولا اقصى حد يفعل ذلك في 2020
لذا بالتاكيد سيكررها ولكننا لا نعرف بعد
هل سيترشح اولا 15 راح يبين شكرا جزيلا يا
سيد احمد
الحنطي شكرا جزيلا ايضا يا سيد حسين عبد
الحسين شكرا لكم
[موسيقى]